Jake:来师傅我们来了
Jake: Master, we're here.
Jake:我们来了我们来了
Jake: We're here, we're here.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:干活干活
Jake: Let's get to work.
Tasha: 干什么活
Tasha: What work?
Jake:陪您加班
Jake: Overtime with you.
Tasha: 没有加班呀
Tasha: There's no overtime.
Jake:我门要干什么
Jake: What are we supposed to do?
Tasha: 没有呀
Tasha: Nothing.
Jake:没有了嗯有
Jake: Nothing? Oh, there is.
其他人：牛的
Others: Impressive.
Jake:牛的
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:不要做什么了
Jake: Don't do anything.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:那这个是干吗的
Jake: What's this for?
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
其他人：她那个眼镜打上了
Others: Her glasses are on.
Jake:打上了好行
Jake: They're on? Okay.
Tasha: 没了嗯
Tasha: That's it, hmm.
Jake:没了
Jake: That's it.
Jake:这是做完了
Jake: It's done.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
其他人：对就这个
Others: Yes, just this.
其他人：蛋清不要了
Others: No egg whites needed.
Jake:倒了是吧
Jake: Throw them out, right?
其他人：哦或者煎个鸡蛋清
Others: Or maybe fry some egg whites.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:煎蛋清是个什么操作
Jake: What's the deal with frying egg whites?
其他人：就是吃蛋白呗
Others: Just eating the protein.
Jake:也还行是吧
Jake: That's okay, right?
Jake:这东西听起来可以吃
Jake: It sounds edible.
其他人：吃吗要吃我给你做
Others: Want to eat it? I'll make it for you.
Jake:吃吃吃做一个
Jake: Sure, sure, make one.
Jake:开火开火
Jake: Fire it up, fire it up.
Jake:把什么地沟油给用了
Jake: Use some of that gutter oil.
其他人：来一小碗试试
Others: Try a small bowl.
有蜡笔：好给师傅多蛋白
Crayon: Okay, more protein for the master.
Jake: 在施工吗
Jake: Are you working?
Lucia:  粘了几张明信片
Lucia: Just sticking some postcards.
Lucia: 不能粘吗
Lucia: Can't I stick them?
Jake:可以加没问题
Jake: Sure, we can add that, no problem.
Lucia: 可以通过时间加班是吗
Lucia: So, we can work overtime, right?
Jake:呃可以加
Jake: Uh, yeah, we can add that.
Jake:因为你的还有一半
Jake: Because you still have half left.
Jake:：我也不知道怎么这么快
Jake: I don't know how it went by so quickly.
Lucia: 哎微微她已经好了
Lucia: Hey, Tasha, she's already done.
Jake:：你已经整理好了
Jake: You're already done organizing?
Lucia: 不是我说她的眼镜
Lucia: No, I meant her glasses.
Lucia: 她的数据已经导了
Lucia: Her data has already been imported.
Jake:：对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Okay then.
Lucia: 为什么又有新的吃的
Lucia: Why is there new food again?
Jake:：是啊就是你看是什么
Jake: Yeah, you see what it is.
Lucia: 鸡蛋
Lucia: Eggs.
Jake:：对鸡蛋白
Jake: Right, egg whites.
其他人：这个鸡蛋还挺好的呢你可以尝尝
Others: These eggs are quite good, you should try them.
Lucia: 煎的吗
Lucia: Are they fried?
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Jake:：试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Lucia: 我们又来了一位大厨
Lucia: We have another great chef here.
Jake:试一下
Jake: Give it a try.
Jake:  为什么蛋白有肉蛋壳啊
Jake: Why are there shells in the egg whites?
Jake: 你嘎哈去了
Jake: Where did you go?
其他人：我上了个厕所
Others: I went to the bathroom.
其他人：你在搞啥
Others: What are you doing?
其他人：上边我还没放盐
Others: I haven't added salt on top yet.
其他人：得稍微放点盐
Others: Need to add a bit of salt.
其他人：下边又太咸了
Others: It's too salty at the bottom.
其他人：稍微放点也只能说勉强能吃
Others: Adding a bit more salt makes it barely edible.
Jake:这也是你的
Jake: This is also yours.
Jake:这是你的什么
Jake: What's this of yours?
Lucia: 这是我的强帖
Lucia: This is my wall sticker.
Jake:墙贴哦
Jake: Wall sticker, oh.
Jake:我给你拆
Jake: Let me unpack it for you.
Jake:我来了
Jake: I'm here.
Jake:可以没有
Jake: Can it work?
Jake:问题不大
Jake: Not a big deal.
Lucia: :嗯这样的吗
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:好吧有点问题我来找找
Jake: Okay, there's a bit of a problem, let me check.
Jake:哎每天都在找剪刀
Jake: Ah, I'm always looking for the scissors.
Jake:找呀找呀找剪刀
Jake: Looking and looking for the scissors.
Lucia:是不是应该多买两把剪刀
Lucia: Should we buy a couple more pairs of scissors?
Jake:多买确实
Jake: Buying more is definitely a good idea.
Lucia:用这个吧这个能托出来
Lucia: Use this one, it can be pulled out.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好有道理
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh man.
Jake:这是直接倒吗
Jake: Do I just pour this directly?
Lucia:能倒出来不
Lucia: Can you pour it out?
Lucia:不能就把
Lucia: If not, just...
Jake:不能
Jake: No, I can't.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my goodness.
Lucia:要不我们就把另外一个
Lucia: How about we just use the other one?
其他人：外边怎么来人了
Other person: Why are there people outside?
Shure: 谁煎鸡蛋了
Shure: Who fried the egg?
Shure: 这什么东西
Shure: What is this?
其他人：只有蛋白
Other person: Only egg white.
Shure: 哦剩的蛋白没用没用啊
Shure: Oh, leftover egg white. It's useless.
Jake:自我审查一下
Jake: Do a self-check.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:你们自我审查一下
Jake: You guys do a self-check.
Jake:你们干嘛呢把把警察给引来了
Jake: What are you doing? You even brought the police over.
Shure: 摄像头开着呢
Shure: The camera's on.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：我要我要开个会
Other person: I need to have a meeting.
Lucia: 这样弄我还得把它剪下来
Lucia: If I do it this way, I'll need to cut it off.
Lucia: 因为它本来是直接贴的直接贴人家墙上
Lucia: Because it was supposed to be directly pasted on the wall.
Jake:那你剪一下呗
Jake: Then just cut it.
Jake:敲敲门没
Jake: Did you knock on the door?
Jake:应该没有
Jake: Probably not.
Jake:都没锁你敲敲门
Jake: It's not locked, just knock.
其他人：两天吃了
Other person: Ate for two days.
Jake:那当然我们来吃了
Jake: Of course, we came to eat.
Jake:大家很谦让
Jake: Everyone is very considerate.
Jake:来吃
Jake: Come and eat.
Lucia: 因为他没有戴上眼镜
Lucia: Because he didn't wear his glasses.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:好好好我给他加加油
Jake: Alright, alright, I'll cheer him on.
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:让他他慢慢来
Lucia: Let him take his time.
Lucia:他他不着急
Lucia: He's not in a hurry.
Jake:我来吃一个
Jake: I'll eat one.
Jake:吃个贵的是吧
Jake: Eat the expensive one, right?
Jake:吃个贵的
Jake: Eat the expensive one.
其他人：为什么这个是贵的
Others: Why is this one expensive?
Jake:这里边巧克力
Jake: There's chocolate inside.
其他人：这还没做呢
Others: It's not done yet.
Tasha: 做了要冷藏两个小时
Tasha: After it's done, it needs to be refrigerated for two hours.
Tasha: 它不用烤啊
Tasha: It doesn't need to be baked.
Tasha: 现在就能吃
Tasha: You can eat it now.
Lucia:这个颜色还可以
Lucia: This color is nice.
Tasha: 我的
Tasha: Mine.
其他人：你怎么不吃呢
Others: Why aren't you eating?
Tasha: 吃不下了
Tasha: I can't eat anymore.
Tasha: 那我还想质问这是谁点的
Tasha: I still want to ask who ordered this.
Tasha: 红牛宝还没吃呢
Tasha: The Red Bull hasn't been eaten yet.
其他人：没吃吗那个
Others: It hasn't been eaten?
Tasha: 比我还浪费
Tasha: It's more wasteful than me.
Tasha: 刚刚那个温度计在哪呀
Tasha: Where's the thermometer from earlier?
Tasha: 温度计
Tasha: Thermometer.
Tasha: 我想测体温他也能测是吗
Tasha: I want to take my temperature. Can it do that?
其他人：啊
Others: Huh?
Tasha: 测体温也能测是吗
Tasha: It can take body temperature, right?
其他人：你发烧了吗
Others: Are you having a fever?
Tasha: 我头有点痛
Tasha: My head hurts a bit.
其他人：你发烧了 这能测体温
Others: You have a fever. This can measure body temperature.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 不能吗
Tasha: Can't it?
Jake:呵呵啊发烧了
Jake: Haha, oh, you have a fever.
Tasha: 有吗
Tasha: Do I?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Tasha: 那就行
Tasha: Then it's fine.
其他人：没有人发烧感冒
Others: No one has a fever or a cold.
Jake:昨天卢亚被狗咬了
Jake: Yesterday, Luyah got bitten by a dog.
Jake:然后就打了两
Jake: Then he got two shots.
Jake:打了一针
Jake: He got one shot.
其他人：就在那个咖啡厅那个
Others: At that coffee shop?
Jake:对啊你去玩过对吧
Jake: Yeah, you went there, right?
Jake:对就那小狗
Jake: Yeah, that little dog.
其他人：那个只要别太招惹它不会咬
Others: As long as you don't provoke it too much, it won't bite.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
其他人：所以昨天你还采集到了打狂犬疫苗
Others: So yesterday you also got the rabies vaccine.
Jake:没有采集到
Jake: No, I didn't get it.
Jake:就是去接他一下
Jake: I just went to pick him up.
Jake:就就这打
Jake: And then got the shot.
Jake:打疫苗的时候咱就没没拍
Jake: We didn't film the vaccination part.
Jake:呵呵呵多多少迪普啊这
Jake: Haha, how many times, this is...
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈别学我说话了
Katrina: Hahaha, stop mimicking me.
Katrina: 学我说话好贱呐耶耶耶
Katrina: Mimicking me sounds so annoying, yay yay yay.
Jake:确实来吃吃吃吃吃吃吃吗
Jake: Indeed. Come on, let's eat, eat, eat.
Katrina: 等一下吃
Katrina: Wait a moment to eat.
Katrina: 我要去拿瓶饮料喝
Katrina: I need to grab a drink.
Shure: 这个蛋糕吗
Shure: This cake?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:这今晚得吃
Jake: We have to eat it tonight.
Jake:明天还得再做一遍
Jake: We'll need to make it again tomorrow.
Jake:因为这这过不了夜
Jake: Because it won't last overnight.
Shure: 过不了夜
Shure: Won't last overnight.
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 全部都得吃完
Katrina: We have to eat it all.
Shure: 这个蛋好吃
Shure: This egg is delicious.
Shure: 你可以拿手抓一块
Shure: You can grab a piece with your hand.
Jake:我再拿一个
Jake: I'll grab another one.
Katrina: 哦买噶
Katrina: Oh my god.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:怎么个牛排
Jake: How about the steak?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：我是专门用牛油煎的蛋
Others: I specially fried the egg with butter.
其他人：卧槽我一吃就吃出来了
Others: Wow, I could taste it right away.
其他人：这边是牛油煎的
Others: This side is fried with butter.
其他人：这边是植物油煎的
Others: This side is fried with vegetable oil.
其他人：还是牛油的好吃
Others: The butter one tastes better.
其他人：  这给素食主义者和这个素食主义者吃
Others: This is for the vegetarians and this vegetarian.
Shure: 素食主义者吃蛋吗
Shure: Do vegetarians eat eggs?
其他人：吃
Others: Yes.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:不知道有有很多种素食主义者
Jake: I don't know, there are many types of vegetarians.
Jake: 我们天天胖10斤
Jake: We gain 10 pounds every day.
Jake:我们现在胖到50斤了
Jake: Now we're up to 50 pounds.
Jake:我跟一开始来
Jake: When I first came
Jake:我变胖了吗
Jake: Have I gained weight?
其他人： 看不出
Others: Can't tell.
其他人：这个只能
Others: This can only be
Jake:只能只能
Jake: Only, only
Jake:我回新加坡去验证一下
Jake: I'll go back to Singapore to check.
Jake:称重我来的时候没称你不知道吧
Jake: I didn't weigh myself when I came, you didn't know that, right?
Katrina: 嗯你要吗
Katrina: Hmm, do you want it?
Katrina: 还有青提跟草莓味
Katrina: There are also green grapes and strawberry flavors.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake:拆一个菠萝的
Jake: Open a pineapple one.
Jake:我靠这怎么吃啊
Jake: Oh man, how do you eat this?
Shure: 我今天晚上开会写东西
Shure: I'm having a meeting and writing stuff tonight.
Jake:我我那
Jake: I, I
Jake:那得拆一下
Jake: That needs to be opened.
Katrina: 还写什么呀
Katrina: What are you writing?
Katrina: 刚不都跟你那个了吗
Katrina: Didn't you just finish that?
Jake:你给我分一下
Jake: Share some with me.
Katrina: 你已经毕业了
Katrina: You've already graduated.
Jake:你怎么也吃不了了
Jake: You can't eat anymore either.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Jake:来分分一下
Jake: Come on, share it.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:你这不行啊
Jake: You're not doing it right.
其他人：我吃这个减肥不减肥
Others: If I eat this, will I lose weight?
其他人：真吃不下了
Others: I really can't eat anymore.
Jake:你你你怎么瘦的呢
Jake: How did you lose weight?
其他人：我怎么瘦的我不知道啊我每天晚上偶读吃东西
Others: How did I lose weight? I don't know, I eat every night.
Katrina: 是什么
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 蛋挞皮吗
Katrina: Is it egg tart crust?
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Damn
Jake:为啥有什么差别
Jake: Why, what's the difference?
其他人：那这个分我一半
Others: Share half of this with me.
其他人：我要尝尝这个菠萝
Others: I want to taste this pineapple.
其他人：这菠萝太甜了
Others: This pineapple is too sweet.
Jake:你这开会怎么没耳机
Jake: Why don't you have headphones in the meeting?
其他人：这和那个生日蛋糕挺像的
Other: This looks a lot like that birthday cake.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 面还有鸡肉卷
Katrina: Noodles and chicken rolls.
Jake:确实很肉松
Jake: It's really meaty.
Jake:对你不吃
Jake: Right, you're not eating it.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay then.
Shure: 还有杯咖啡谁点的没喝
Shure: There's a cup of coffee that no one drank.
Shure: 这种浪费咖啡的行为
Shure: This wasting coffee thing...
Katrina: 这咖啡还牛奶
Katrina: This coffee still has milk.
Jake:谴责强势谴责
Jake: Condemn it, strongly condemn it.
Shure: 一个浪费大的一个浪费牛奶
Shure: One wastes a lot, one wastes milk.
Katrina: 不会有人点咖啡的牛奶吧
Katrina: No one would order coffee with milk, right?
其他人：你见过
Other: Have you seen it?
Shure: 这谁的
Shure: Whose is this?
其他人：那还有一个卷那还有两汉堡
Other: There's another roll, and two burgers.
Shure: 这是牛奶啊这牛奶
Shure: This is milk, yeah, milk.
Katrina: 嗯牛奶吗
Katrina: Yeah, is it milk?
Shure: 嗯牛奶
Shure: Yeah, it's milk.
Katrina: 我刚开
Katrina: I just opened it.
Alice:今天晚上嘎嘎上厕所两杯灌下去
Alice: Tonight, drinking two cups will make you go to the bathroom a lot.
Katrina: 早上你们楼下听到我咚咚咚哈哈哈
Katrina: In the morning, you'll hear me stomping around downstairs, haha.
Shure: 我我单身
Shure: I'm single.
Shure: 但我可以帅
Shure: But I can be cool.
Shure: 我现在是单身吧
Shure: Am I single now?
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 没事你搜点那PNA干活
Katrina: It's okay, you can search for that PNA work.
Jake:哼哼哼你就再也吃
Jake: Haha, you just keep eating.
Katrina: 不要按呀
Katrina: Don't press it.
Katrina: 我也是双眼皮
Katrina: I have double eyelids too.
Katrina: 我是内双
Katrina: I have inner double eyelids.
其他人：你什么双你是全自动双
Other: What kind of double eyelids? You have automatic double eyelids.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:手动双
Alice: Manual double eyelids.
Katrina: 真的
Katrina: Really.
Alice:你要不贴了双眼皮贴吧
Alice: You should put on double eyelid tape.
Shure: 有贴双眼皮贴眼镜会大
Shure: Putting on double eyelid tape makes your eyes look bigger.
其他人：又双眼皮贴吗
Other: Do you have double eyelid tape?
Katrina: 有啊你们应该有
Katrina: Yeah, you guys should have some.
Katrina: 快搜一下q n a chat gpt搞一下
Katrina: Quickly search for QNA chat GPT, do something.
Katrina: 我没有
Katrina: I don't have it.
Jake:来搜搜搜搜搜搜
Jake: Come on, search, search, search!
Shure: 二楼谈一下QandA吧
Shure: Let's discuss the Q&A on the second floor.
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina: 速度
Katrina: Hurry up.
Shure: 二楼那个能投屏
Shure: The second floor can do screen projection.
Jake:二楼什么投屏啊
Jake: What kind of screen projection on the second floor?
Jake:行那你抱着电脑去吧
Jake: Fine, then take the computer with you.
Jake:你你用什么东西搜
Jake: What are you using to search?
Shure: 我用我用GPT搜你
Shure: I'll use GPT to search for you.
Jake:你用GP行
Jake: You're using GPT, okay.
Katrina: 赞
Katrina: Cool.
Katrina: 上哦我看见我的这个
Katrina: Look, I found my thing.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Katrina: 这是我的画挂画
Katrina: This is my painting, my hanging painting.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:请
Jake: Please.
Katrina: 好好好又找不到我的
Katrina: Alright, alright, can't find my stuff again.
Jake:什么刀啊
Jake: What knife?
Katrina: 剪刀
Katrina: Scissors.
Jake:我们刚刚也没用
Jake: We didn't use them just now.
Jake:呵呵我给你开了
Jake: Haha, I opened it for you.
Alice:眼镜还没好吗
Alice: Are your glasses not ready yet?
Jake:你眼镜确实没好哎
Jake: Your glasses really aren't ready, huh.
Jake:我靠你眼镜好了
Jake: Whoa, your glasses are fixed!
Katrina: 那你下班了睡觉去吧
Katrina: Then go to sleep after you finish work.
Katrina: （歌词）i found a girl
Katrina: (Lyrics) I found a girl
Katrina: （歌词）beautiful and sweet
Katrina: (Lyrics) Beautiful and sweet
Tasha: 困了
Tasha: I'm sleepy.
Katrina: 10点上班
Katrina: Work starts at 10.
Alice:上钟
Alice: Let's get started.
Katrina: 最开始洗头
Katrina: Start with washing hair.
Alice:我们半个小时结束吗
Alice: Can we finish in half an hour?
Jake:能能能能能
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, we can.
Jake:很能特别能
Jake: Definitely can, especially can.
Jake:我们直接上去吧
Jake: Let's go straight up.
Jake:直接上去吧
Jake:你你你这个确实没打好
Jake: You, you, you didn't do this well.
Katrina: 我可以戴久一点
Katrina: I can wear it a bit longer.
Katrina: 因为我有很多事要干
Katrina: Because I have a lot of things to do.
Jake:好的倒还是不倒
Jake: Alright, whether to pour or not to pour.
Alice:倒还是不倒戴还是不戴呢
Alice: Should I wear it or not?
Jake:呃你你这个嗯嗯呵
Jake: Uh, you, this, um...
Jake:呵你这个就断了
Jake: Oh, it just broke.
Jake:你这你这你这个电
Jake: This, this power...
Jake:你这眼镜他可喜欢断
Jake: This glasses, they really like to break.
Jake:但是这不是你的问题
Jake: But it's not your fault.
Katrina: （歌词）i found a girl beautiful and sweet
Katrina: (lyrics) I found a girl beautiful and sweet
Alice:能看到进度吗
Alice: Can you see the progress?
Jake:是断了就很惨
Jake: If it breaks, it's bad.
Jake:所以没办法
Jake: So there's no choice.
Jake:你就戴一会吧
Jake: Just wear it for a while.
Jake:因为没有办法
Jake: Because there's no choice.
Jake:就是你戴一会
Jake: Just wear it for a while.
Jake:然后他他只剩不多的storage
Jake: And then, there's not much storage left.
Jake:所以说停了就录到哪就录到哪
Jake: So, if it stops, it stops.
Alice:录到哪就
Alice: If it stops, it stops.
Jake:是了对你不用充电了
Jake: Yes, you don't need to charge it.
Alice:哪还有充电吗
Alice: Is there any charging left?
Jake:因为这电足够你录到那个时间
Jake: Because the power is enough for you to record until then.
Jake:哈哈哈哈对对对
Jake: Hahaha, yes, yes.
Jake:我就断了
Jake: Then it broke.
Jake:就黑屏呗
Jake: Just a black screen.
Jake:就
Jake: Just...
Jake:走走走我们一起走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go together.
Jake:走走走行
Jake: Let's go, alright?
Jake:一会上去玩玩吧
Jake: Let's go upstairs and play a bit.
Katrina: 我是那种一年心情好一次全部整理
Katrina: I'm the type to tidy up once a year when I'm in a good mood.
Katrina: 那你这心情不好排解的方法还挺健康
Katrina: Your way of dealing with a bad mood is pretty healthy.
Katrina: 哎我是不没没开啊
Katrina: Oh, did I not turn it on?
Katrina: 我亮了吗哦亮了
Katrina: Is it on? Oh, it's on.
Katrina: 放歌了
Katrina: Playing music now.
Katrina: 感觉少点music少点灵魂
Katrina: Feels like it lacks a bit of soul without music.
Jake:太尼玛慢了
Jake: So damn slow.
Katrina: 上钟 噔噔噔
Katrina: Time's up. Ding ding ding.
Jake:吼
Jake: Roar.
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:这是宇轩的
Jake: This is Yuxuan's.
Jake:我我给他拆拆一下
Jake: I'll take it apart for him.
Katrina: 没什么不能看的呀
Katrina: There's nothing you can't look at.
Katrina: 大家都是成年人
Katrina: We're all adults here.
Shure: 不是刚喝一口
Shure: Didn't you just take a sip?
Shure: 怎么就开始虎狼了呢
Shure: Why are you getting all wild now?
其他人：可以那天晚上喝多了那个
Others: Maybe because you drank too much that night.
Katrina: 我怎么了
Katrina: What happened to me?
Katrina: 火锅那回吗
Katrina: Are you talking about that hot pot night?
Katrina: 那天你们都没套出我本优男的话了
Katrina: That night, none of you could get me to spill my secrets.
Katrina: 说明我还行
Katrina: So, I'm still good.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 你们喝的都太慢了
Shure: You all drink too slowly.
Jake:啊你这就讨论了
Jake: Ah, now you're discussing it.
Jake:云服务器
Jake: Cloud servers.
Jake:讨论讨论iOS系统传
Jake: Discussing the iOS system transfer.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:请请请说
Jake: Please, please, go ahead.
Shure: 就是那个他
Shure: It's just that...
Shure: 那个就是开唱调用不了的你的眼镜啊
Shure: That thing, you couldn't call it with your glasses.
Jake:啊没有
Jake: Ah, no.
Jake:他还没唱完呢
Jake: He hasn't finished singing yet.
Jake:他还有几分钟
Jake: He has a few more minutes.
Shure: 它那个调用不了麦克风
Shure: It couldn't call the microphone.
Jake:拍唱
Jake: Karaoke.
Jake:第二步
Jake: The second step.
Shure: 就是mac版本的拍唱调用不了麦克风
Shure: The Mac version of karaoke couldn't call the microphone.
Jake:你别用你不用拍唱
Jake: Don't use it, just use the command line, okay?
Jake:跑你用命令行跑行吗
Jake: Can you run it with the command line?
Jake:开唱里边有命令行吗
Jake: Does karaoke have a command line?
Jake:你用同样的命令去跑他
Jake: Use the same command to run it.
Shure:  要有一个界面就是ui界面ui做的
Shure: There should be a UI interface, the UI is made.
Jake:那你可以命令行他跳出来
Jake: You can make it pop up with the command line.
Shure: 啊也可以是吧
Shure: Ah, that works too, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 然后这样的话就ok了
Shure: Then it's okay.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:你就跳过拍唱他的这个傻逼东西
Jake: Just skip the karaoke, that stupid thing.
Jake:好这答辩了这呵呵呵
Jake: Alright, this concludes the defense, haha.
Shure: 哦对我当时好像确实是这么弄的
Shure: Oh right, I think that's how I did it back then.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Shure: 感谢杨老板一会给你刷一个穿云箭
Shure: Thanks, Jake. I'll send you a cloud arrow later.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Shure: how can i help you today
Shure: How can I help you today?
Shure: today we will talk about
Shure: Today we will talk about...
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure: perfect
Shure: Perfect.
Jake:也能够圣旨上来
Jake: Also, can we bring the decree up?
Shure: 我们用中文还是用英文
Shure: Should we use Chinese or English?
Jake:啊你想咋样咋样呗
Jake: Ah, whichever you prefer.
Shure: 中文吧
Shure: Let's go with Chinese.
Jake:中文可以啊
Jake: Chinese is fine.
Jake:就中文吧
Jake: Yeah, let's use Chinese.
Katrina: 我靠这玩意不是有甲醛吗
Katrina: Oh my god, doesn't this thing have formaldehyde?
Jake:啊你
Jake: Ah, you...
Jake:哦我靠
Jake: Oh my god...
Tasha: 就是按照他最后的那个参考文献
Tasha: Just follow his final reference.
Tasha: 不是有1234
Tasha: Isn't it numbered 1, 2, 3, 4?
Tasha: 一直有20个吗
Tasha: There are always 20, right?
Tasha: 然后你看着文章中不是也有吗
Tasha: And you see, in the article, it's also there.
Tasha: 就是呃不是按那个一页来说是12345
Tasha: So, um, instead of numbering the pages as 1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
Tasha: 而是说看文章参考文献
Tasha: You look at the references in the article.
Tasha: 比如说这个参考文献在在文章中是5
Tasha: For example, if the reference in the article is 5...
Tasha: 然后你就标个5的上标就行
Tasha: You just mark it as 5.
Tasha: 就是呃也不用全部都标上
Tasha: So, um, you don't have to mark all of them.
Tasha: 不是说有20个参考文献
Tasha: It's not like there are 20 references...
Tasha: 我们就一定要在文章中标到
Tasha: And we have to mark all 20 in the article.
Tasha: 标满20个
Tasha: Mark all 20.
Tasha: 就是文章中
Tasha: In the article...
Tasha: 还是按照原来角著的地方吧
Tasha: Just follow the original annotations.
Tasha: 就是
Tasha: Just...
Tasha: 跟我们以前写论文的方法是一样的
Tasha: Like the way we used to write papers.
Tasha: 不用对就这样子
Tasha: No need to... yeah, just like that.
Lucia:嘉宾会以为他们来到了28吧
Lucia: The guests might think they are in room 28.
Jake:哈哈哈是
Jake: Hahaha, indeed.
Lucia:我眼睛有点散光
Lucia: My eyes are a bit astigmatic.
Jake:卧槽本来就不清楚
Jake: Whoa, it's not clear to begin with.
Jake:跟你眼睛没关系
Jake: It's not about your eyes.
Jake:哈哈哈我到这我到这我都看不清
Jake: Hahaha, I can't see clearly from here.
Jake:来师傅我们来了
Jake: Master, we're here.
Jake:我们来了我们来了
Jake: We're here, we're here.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:干活干活
Jake: Let's get to work.
Tasha: 干什么活
Tasha: What work?
Jake:陪您加班
Jake: Overtime with you.
Tasha: 没有加班呀
Tasha: There's no overtime.
Jake:我门要干什么
Jake: What are we supposed to do?
Tasha: 没有呀
Tasha: Nothing.
Jake:没有了嗯有
Jake: Nothing? Oh, there is.
其他人：牛的
Others: Impressive.
Jake:牛的
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:不要做什么了
Jake: Don't do anything.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:那这个是干吗的
Jake: What's this for?
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
其他人：她那个眼镜打上了
Others: Her glasses are on.
Jake:打上了好行
Jake: They're on? Okay.
Tasha: 没了嗯
Tasha: That's it, hmm.
Jake:没了
Jake: That's it.
Jake:这是做完了
Jake: It's done.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
其他人：对就这个
Others: Yes, just this.
其他人：蛋清不要了
Others: No egg whites needed.
Jake:倒了是吧
Jake: Throw them out, right?
其他人：哦或者煎个鸡蛋清
Others: Or maybe fry some egg whites.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:煎蛋清是个什么操作
Jake: What's the deal with frying egg whites?
其他人：就是吃蛋白呗
Others: Just eating the protein.
Jake:也还行是吧
Jake: That's okay, right?
Jake:这东西听起来可以吃
Jake: It sounds edible.
其他人：吃吗要吃我给你做
Others: Want to eat it? I'll make it for you.
Jake:吃吃吃做一个
Jake: Sure, sure, make one.
Jake:开火开火
Jake: Fire it up, fire it up.
Jake:把什么地沟油给用了
Jake: Use some of that gutter oil.
其他人：来一小碗试试
Others: Try a small bowl.
有蜡笔：好给师傅多蛋白
Crayon: Okay, more protein for the master.
Jake: 在施工吗
Jake: Are you working?
Lucia:  粘了几张明信片
Lucia: Just sticking some postcards.
Lucia: 不能粘吗
Lucia: Can't I stick them?
Jake:可以加没问题
Jake: Sure, we can add that, no problem.
Lucia: 可以通过时间加班是吗
Lucia: So, we can work overtime, right?
Jake:呃可以加
Jake: Uh, yeah, we can add that.
Jake:因为你的还有一半
Jake: Because you still have half left.
Jake:：我也不知道怎么这么快
Jake: I don't know how it went by so quickly.
Lucia: 哎微微她已经好了
Lucia: Hey, Tasha, she's already done.
Jake:：你已经整理好了
Jake: You're already done organizing?
Lucia: 不是我说她的眼镜
Lucia: No, I meant her glasses.
Lucia: 她的数据已经导了
Lucia: Her data has already been imported.
Jake:：对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Okay then.
Lucia: 为什么又有新的吃的
Lucia: Why is there new food again?
Jake:：是啊就是你看是什么
Jake: Yeah, you see what it is.
Lucia: 鸡蛋
Lucia: Eggs.
Jake:：对鸡蛋白
Jake: Right, egg whites.
其他人：这个鸡蛋还挺好的呢你可以尝尝
Others: These eggs are quite good, you should try them.
Lucia: 煎的吗
Lucia: Are they fried?
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Jake:：试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Lucia: 我们又来了一位大厨
Lucia: We have another great chef here.
Jake:试一下
Jake: Give it a try.
Jake:  为什么蛋白有肉蛋壳啊
Jake: Why are there shells in the egg whites?
Jake: 你嘎哈去了
Jake: Where did you go?
其他人：我上了个厕所
Others: I went to the bathroom.
其他人：你在搞啥
Others: What are you doing?
其他人：上边我还没放盐
Others: I haven't added salt on top yet.
其他人：得稍微放点盐
Others: Need to add a bit of salt.
其他人：下边又太咸了
Others: It's too salty at the bottom.
其他人：稍微放点也只能说勉强能吃
Others: Adding a bit more salt makes it barely edible.
Jake:这也是你的
Jake: This is also yours.
Jake:这是你的什么
Jake: What's this of yours?
Lucia: 这是我的强帖
Lucia: This is my wall sticker.
Jake:墙贴哦
Jake: Wall sticker, oh.
Jake:我给你拆
Jake: Let me unpack it for you.
Jake:我来了
Jake: I'm here.
Jake:可以没有
Jake: Can it work?
Jake:问题不大
Jake: Not a big deal.
Lucia: :嗯这样的吗
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:好吧有点问题我来找找
Jake: Okay, there's a bit of a problem, let me check.
Jake:哎每天都在找剪刀
Jake: Ah, I'm always looking for the scissors.
Jake:找呀找呀找剪刀
Jake: Looking and looking for the scissors.
Lucia:是不是应该多买两把剪刀
Lucia: Should we buy a couple more pairs of scissors?
Jake:多买确实
Jake: Buying more is definitely a good idea.
Lucia:用这个吧这个能托出来
Lucia: Use this one, it can be pulled out.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好有道理
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh man.
Jake:这是直接倒吗
Jake: Do I just pour this directly?
Lucia:能倒出来不
Lucia: Can you pour it out?
Lucia:不能就把
Lucia: If not, just...
Jake:不能
Jake: No, I can't.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my goodness.
Lucia:要不我们就把另外一个
Lucia: How about we just use the other one?
其他人：外边怎么来人了
Other person: Why are there people outside?
Shure: 谁煎鸡蛋了
Shure: Who fried the egg?
Shure: 这什么东西
Shure: What is this?
其他人：只有蛋白
Other person: Only egg white.
Shure: 哦剩的蛋白没用没用啊
Shure: Oh, leftover egg white. It's useless.
Jake:自我审查一下
Jake: Do a self-check.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:你们自我审查一下
Jake: You guys do a self-check.
Jake:你们干嘛呢把把警察给引来了
Jake: What are you doing? You even brought the police over.
Shure: 摄像头开着呢
Shure: The camera's on.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：我要我要开个会
Other person: I need to have a meeting.
Lucia: 这样弄我还得把它剪下来
Lucia: If I do it this way, I'll need to cut it off.
Lucia: 因为它本来是直接贴的直接贴人家墙上
Lucia: Because it was supposed to be directly pasted on the wall.
Jake:那你剪一下呗
Jake: Then just cut it.
Jake:敲敲门没
Jake: Did you knock on the door?
Jake:应该没有
Jake: Probably not.
Jake:都没锁你敲敲门
Jake: It's not locked, just knock.
其他人：两天吃了
Other person: Ate for two days.
Jake:那当然我们来吃了
Jake: Of course, we came to eat.
Jake:大家很谦让
Jake: Everyone is very considerate.
Jake:来吃
Jake: Come and eat.
Lucia: 因为他没有戴上眼镜
Lucia: Because he didn't wear his glasses.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:好好好我给他加加油
Jake: Alright, alright, I'll cheer him on.
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:让他他慢慢来
Lucia: Let him take his time.
Lucia:他他不着急
Lucia: He's not in a hurry.
Jake:我来吃一个
Jake: I'll eat one.
Jake:吃个贵的是吧
Jake: Eat the expensive one, right?
Jake:吃个贵的
Jake: Eat the expensive one.
其他人：为什么这个是贵的
Others: Why is this one expensive?
Jake:这里边巧克力
Jake: There's chocolate inside.
其他人：这还没做呢
Others: It's not done yet.
Tasha: 做了要冷藏两个小时
Tasha: After it's done, it needs to be refrigerated for two hours.
Tasha: 它不用烤啊
Tasha: It doesn't need to be baked.
Tasha: 现在就能吃
Tasha: You can eat it now.
Lucia:这个颜色还可以
Lucia: This color is nice.
Tasha: 我的
Tasha: Mine.
其他人：你怎么不吃呢
Others: Why aren't you eating?
Tasha: 吃不下了
Tasha: I can't eat anymore.
Tasha: 那我还想质问这是谁点的
Tasha: I still want to ask who ordered this.
Tasha: 红牛宝还没吃呢
Tasha: The Red Bull hasn't been eaten yet.
其他人：没吃吗那个
Others: It hasn't been eaten?
Tasha: 比我还浪费
Tasha: It's more wasteful than me.
Tasha: 刚刚那个温度计在哪呀
Tasha: Where's the thermometer from earlier?
Tasha: 温度计
Tasha: Thermometer.
Tasha: 我想测体温他也能测是吗
Tasha: I want to take my temperature. Can it do that?
其他人：啊
Others: Huh?
Tasha: 测体温也能测是吗
Tasha: It can take body temperature, right?
其他人：你发烧了吗
Others: Are you having a fever?
Tasha: 我头有点痛
Tasha: My head hurts a bit.
其他人：你发烧了 这能测体温
Others: You have a fever. This can measure body temperature.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 不能吗
Tasha: Can't it?
Jake:呵呵啊发烧了
Jake: Haha, oh, you have a fever.
Tasha: 有吗
Tasha: Do I?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Tasha: 那就行
Tasha: Then it's fine.
其他人：没有人发烧感冒
Others: No one has a fever or a cold.
Jake:昨天卢亚被狗咬了
Jake: Yesterday, Luyah got bitten by a dog.
Jake:然后就打了两
Jake: Then he got two shots.
Jake:打了一针
Jake: He got one shot.
其他人：就在那个咖啡厅那个
Others: At that coffee shop?
Jake:对啊你去玩过对吧
Jake: Yeah, you went there, right?
Jake:对就那小狗
Jake: Yeah, that little dog.
其他人：那个只要别太招惹它不会咬
Others: As long as you don't provoke it too much, it won't bite.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
其他人：所以昨天你还采集到了打狂犬疫苗
Others: So yesterday you also got the rabies vaccine.
Jake:没有采集到
Jake: No, I didn't get it.
Jake:就是去接他一下
Jake: I just went to pick him up.
Jake:就就这打
Jake: And then got the shot.
Jake:打疫苗的时候咱就没没拍
Jake: We didn't film the vaccination part.
Jake:呵呵呵多多少迪普啊这
Jake: Haha, how many times, this is...
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈别学我说话了
Katrina: Hahaha, stop mimicking me.
Katrina: 学我说话好贱呐耶耶耶
Katrina: Mimicking me sounds so annoying, yay yay yay.
Jake:确实来吃吃吃吃吃吃吃吗
Jake: Indeed. Come on, let's eat, eat, eat.
Katrina: 等一下吃
Katrina: Wait a moment to eat.
Katrina: 我要去拿瓶饮料喝
Katrina: I need to grab a drink.
Shure: 这个蛋糕吗
Shure: This cake?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:这今晚得吃
Jake: We have to eat it tonight.
Jake:明天还得再做一遍
Jake: We'll need to make it again tomorrow.
Jake:因为这这过不了夜
Jake: Because it won't last overnight.
Shure: 过不了夜
Shure: Won't last overnight.
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 全部都得吃完
Katrina: We have to eat it all.
Shure: 这个蛋好吃
Shure: This egg is delicious.
Shure: 你可以拿手抓一块
Shure: You can grab a piece with your hand.
Jake:我再拿一个
Jake: I'll grab another one.
Katrina: 哦买噶
Katrina: Oh my god.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:怎么个牛排
Jake: How about the steak?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：我是专门用牛油煎的蛋
Others: I specially fried the egg with butter.
其他人：卧槽我一吃就吃出来了
Others: Wow, I could taste it right away.
其他人：这边是牛油煎的
Others: This side is fried with butter.
其他人：这边是植物油煎的
Others: This side is fried with vegetable oil.
其他人：还是牛油的好吃
Others: The butter one tastes better.
其他人：  这给素食主义者和这个素食主义者吃
Others: This is for the vegetarians and this vegetarian.
Shure: 素食主义者吃蛋吗
Shure: Do vegetarians eat eggs?
其他人：吃
Others: Yes.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:不知道有有很多种素食主义者
Jake: I don't know, there are many types of vegetarians.
Jake: 我们天天胖10斤
Jake: We gain 10 pounds every day.
Jake:我们现在胖到50斤了
Jake: Now we're up to 50 pounds.
Jake:我跟一开始来
Jake: When I first came
Jake:我变胖了吗
Jake: Have I gained weight?
其他人： 看不出
Others: Can't tell.
其他人：这个只能
Others: This can only be
Jake:只能只能
Jake: Only, only
Jake:我回新加坡去验证一下
Jake: I'll go back to Singapore to check.
Jake:称重我来的时候没称你不知道吧
Jake: I didn't weigh myself when I came, you didn't know that, right?
Katrina: 嗯你要吗
Katrina: Hmm, do you want it?
Katrina: 还有青提跟草莓味
Katrina: There are also green grapes and strawberry flavors.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake:拆一个菠萝的
Jake: Open a pineapple one.
Jake:我靠这怎么吃啊
Jake: Oh man, how do you eat this?
Shure: 我今天晚上开会写东西
Shure: I'm having a meeting and writing stuff tonight.
Jake:我我那
Jake: I, I
Jake:那得拆一下
Jake: That needs to be opened.
Katrina: 还写什么呀
Katrina: What are you writing?
Katrina: 刚不都跟你那个了吗
Katrina: Didn't you just finish that?
Jake:你给我分一下
Jake: Share some with me.
Katrina: 你已经毕业了
Katrina: You've already graduated.
Jake:你怎么也吃不了了
Jake: You can't eat anymore either.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Jake:来分分一下
Jake: Come on, share it.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:你这不行啊
Jake: You're not doing it right.
其他人：我吃这个减肥不减肥
Others: If I eat this, will I lose weight?
其他人：真吃不下了
Others: I really can't eat anymore.
Jake:你你你怎么瘦的呢
Jake: How did you lose weight?
其他人：我怎么瘦的我不知道啊我每天晚上偶读吃东西
Others: How did I lose weight? I don't know, I eat every night.
Katrina: 是什么
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 蛋挞皮吗
Katrina: Is it egg tart crust?
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Damn
Jake:为啥有什么差别
Jake: Why, what's the difference?
其他人：那这个分我一半
Others: Share half of this with me.
其他人：我要尝尝这个菠萝
Others: I want to taste this pineapple.
其他人：这菠萝太甜了
Others: This pineapple is too sweet.
Jake:你这开会怎么没耳机
Jake: Why don't you have headphones in the meeting?
其他人：这和那个生日蛋糕挺像的
Other: This looks a lot like that birthday cake.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 面还有鸡肉卷
Katrina: Noodles and chicken rolls.
Jake:确实很肉松
Jake: It's really meaty.
Jake:对你不吃
Jake: Right, you're not eating it.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay then.
Shure: 还有杯咖啡谁点的没喝
Shure: There's a cup of coffee that no one drank.
Shure: 这种浪费咖啡的行为
Shure: This wasting coffee thing...
Katrina: 这咖啡还牛奶
Katrina: This coffee still has milk.
Jake:谴责强势谴责
Jake: Condemn it, strongly condemn it.
Shure: 一个浪费大的一个浪费牛奶
Shure: One wastes a lot, one wastes milk.
Katrina: 不会有人点咖啡的牛奶吧
Katrina: No one would order coffee with milk, right?
其他人：你见过
Other: Have you seen it?
Shure: 这谁的
Shure: Whose is this?
其他人：那还有一个卷那还有两汉堡
Other: There's another roll, and two burgers.
Shure: 这是牛奶啊这牛奶
Shure: This is milk, yeah, milk.
Katrina: 嗯牛奶吗
Katrina: Yeah, is it milk?
Shure: 嗯牛奶
Shure: Yeah, it's milk.
Katrina: 我刚开
Katrina: I just opened it.
Alice:今天晚上嘎嘎上厕所两杯灌下去
Alice: Tonight, drinking two cups will make you go to the bathroom a lot.
Katrina: 早上你们楼下听到我咚咚咚哈哈哈
Katrina: In the morning, you'll hear me stomping around downstairs, haha.
Shure: 我我单身
Shure: I'm single.
Shure: 但我可以帅
Shure: But I can be cool.
Shure: 我现在是单身吧
Shure: Am I single now?
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 没事你搜点那PNA干活
Katrina: It's okay, you can search for that PNA work.
Jake:哼哼哼你就再也吃
Jake: Haha, you just keep eating.
Katrina: 不要按呀
Katrina: Don't press it.
Katrina: 我也是双眼皮
Katrina: I have double eyelids too.
Katrina: 我是内双
Katrina: I have inner double eyelids.
其他人：你什么双你是全自动双
Other: What kind of double eyelids? You have automatic double eyelids.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:手动双
Alice: Manual double eyelids.
Katrina: 真的
Katrina: Really.
Alice:你要不贴了双眼皮贴吧
Alice: You should put on double eyelid tape.
Shure: 有贴双眼皮贴眼镜会大
Shure: Putting on double eyelid tape makes your eyes look bigger.
其他人：又双眼皮贴吗
Other: Do you have double eyelid tape?
Katrina: 有啊你们应该有
Katrina: Yeah, you guys should have some.
Katrina: 快搜一下q n a chat gpt搞一下
Katrina: Quickly search for QNA chat GPT, do something.
Katrina: 我没有
Katrina: I don't have it.
Jake:来搜搜搜搜搜搜
Jake: Come on, search, search, search!
Shure: 二楼谈一下QandA吧
Shure: Let's discuss the Q&A on the second floor.
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina: 速度
Katrina: Hurry up.
Shure: 二楼那个能投屏
Shure: The second floor can do screen projection.
Jake:二楼什么投屏啊
Jake: What kind of screen projection on the second floor?
Jake:行那你抱着电脑去吧
Jake: Fine, then take the computer with you.
Jake:你你用什么东西搜
Jake: What are you using to search?
Shure: 我用我用GPT搜你
Shure: I'll use GPT to search for you.
Jake:你用GP行
Jake: You're using GPT, okay.
Katrina: 赞
Katrina: Cool.
Katrina: 上哦我看见我的这个
Katrina: Look, I found my thing.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Katrina: 这是我的画挂画
Katrina: This is my painting, my hanging painting.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:请
Jake: Please.
Katrina: 好好好又找不到我的
Katrina: Alright, alright, can't find my stuff again.
Jake:什么刀啊
Jake: What knife?
Katrina: 剪刀
Katrina: Scissors.
Jake:我们刚刚也没用
Jake: We didn't use them just now.
Jake:呵呵我给你开了
Jake: Haha, I opened it for you.
Alice:眼镜还没好吗
Alice: Are your glasses not ready yet?
Jake:你眼镜确实没好哎
Jake: Your glasses really aren't ready, huh.
Jake:我靠你眼镜好了
Jake: Whoa, your glasses are fixed!
Katrina: 那你下班了睡觉去吧
Katrina: Then go to sleep after you finish work.
Katrina: （歌词）i found a girl
Katrina: (Lyrics) I found a girl
Katrina: （歌词）beautiful and sweet
Katrina: (Lyrics) Beautiful and sweet
Tasha: 困了
Tasha: I'm sleepy.
Katrina: 10点上班
Katrina: Work starts at 10.
Alice:上钟
Alice: Let's get started.
Katrina: 最开始洗头
Katrina: Start with washing hair.
Alice:我们半个小时结束吗
Alice: Can we finish in half an hour?
Jake:能能能能能
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, we can.
Jake:很能特别能
Jake: Definitely can, especially can.
Jake:我们直接上去吧
Jake: Let's go straight up.
Jake:直接上去吧
Jake:你你你这个确实没打好
Jake: You, you, you didn't do this well.
Katrina: 我可以戴久一点
Katrina: I can wear it a bit longer.
Katrina: 因为我有很多事要干
Katrina: Because I have a lot of things to do.
Jake:好的倒还是不倒
Jake: Alright, whether to pour or not to pour.
Alice:倒还是不倒戴还是不戴呢
Alice: Should I wear it or not?
Jake:呃你你这个嗯嗯呵
Jake: Uh, you, this, um...
Jake:呵你这个就断了
Jake: Oh, it just broke.
Jake:你这你这你这个电
Jake: This, this power...
Jake:你这眼镜他可喜欢断
Jake: This glasses, they really like to break.
Jake:但是这不是你的问题
Jake: But it's not your fault.
Katrina: （歌词）i found a girl beautiful and sweet
Katrina: (lyrics) I found a girl beautiful and sweet
Alice:能看到进度吗
Alice: Can you see the progress?
Jake:是断了就很惨
Jake: If it breaks, it's bad.
Jake:所以没办法
Jake: So there's no choice.
Jake:你就戴一会吧
Jake: Just wear it for a while.
Jake:因为没有办法
Jake: Because there's no choice.
Jake:就是你戴一会
Jake: Just wear it for a while.
Jake:然后他他只剩不多的storage
Jake: And then, there's not much storage left.
Jake:所以说停了就录到哪就录到哪
Jake: So, if it stops, it stops.
Alice:录到哪就
Alice: If it stops, it stops.
Jake:是了对你不用充电了
Jake: Yes, you don't need to charge it.
Alice:哪还有充电吗
Alice: Is there any charging left?
Jake:因为这电足够你录到那个时间
Jake: Because the power is enough for you to record until then.
Jake:哈哈哈哈对对对
Jake: Hahaha, yes, yes.
Jake:我就断了
Jake: Then it broke.
Jake:就黑屏呗
Jake: Just a black screen.
Jake:就
Jake: Just...
Jake:走走走我们一起走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go together.
Jake:走走走行
Jake: Let's go, alright?
Jake:一会上去玩玩吧
Jake: Let's go upstairs and play a bit.
Katrina: 我是那种一年心情好一次全部整理
Katrina: I'm the type to tidy up once a year when I'm in a good mood.
Katrina: 那你这心情不好排解的方法还挺健康
Katrina: Your way of dealing with a bad mood is pretty healthy.
Katrina: 哎我是不没没开啊
Katrina: Oh, did I not turn it on?
Katrina: 我亮了吗哦亮了
Katrina: Is it on? Oh, it's on.
Katrina: 放歌了
Katrina: Playing music now.
Katrina: 感觉少点music少点灵魂
Katrina: Feels like it lacks a bit of soul without music.
Jake:太尼玛慢了
Jake: So damn slow.
Katrina: 上钟 噔噔噔
Katrina: Time's up. Ding ding ding.
Jake:吼
Jake: Roar.
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:这是宇轩的
Jake: This is Yuxuan's.
Jake:我我给他拆拆一下
Jake: I'll take it apart for him.
Katrina: 没什么不能看的呀
Katrina: There's nothing you can't look at.
Katrina: 大家都是成年人
Katrina: We're all adults here.
Shure: 不是刚喝一口
Shure: Didn't you just take a sip?
Shure: 怎么就开始虎狼了呢
Shure: Why are you getting all wild now?
其他人：可以那天晚上喝多了那个
Others: Maybe because you drank too much that night.
Katrina: 我怎么了
Katrina: What happened to me?
Katrina: 火锅那回吗
Katrina: Are you talking about that hot pot night?
Katrina: 那天你们都没套出我本优男的话了
Katrina: That night, none of you could get me to spill my secrets.
Katrina: 说明我还行
Katrina: So, I'm still good.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 你们喝的都太慢了
Shure: You all drink too slowly.
Jake:啊你这就讨论了
Jake: Ah, now you're discussing it.
Jake:云服务器
Jake: Cloud servers.
Jake:讨论讨论iOS系统传
Jake: Discussing the iOS system transfer.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:请请请说
Jake: Please, please, go ahead.
Shure: 就是那个他
Shure: It's just that...
Shure: 那个就是开唱调用不了的你的眼镜啊
Shure: That thing, you couldn't call it with your glasses.
Jake:啊没有
Jake: Ah, no.
Jake:他还没唱完呢
Jake: He hasn't finished singing yet.
Jake:他还有几分钟
Jake: He has a few more minutes.
Shure: 它那个调用不了麦克风
Shure: It couldn't call the microphone.
Jake:拍唱
Jake: Karaoke.
Jake:第二步
Jake: The second step.
Shure: 就是mac版本的拍唱调用不了麦克风
Shure: The Mac version of karaoke couldn't call the microphone.
Jake:你别用你不用拍唱
Jake: Don't use it, just use the command line, okay?
Jake:跑你用命令行跑行吗
Jake: Can you run it with the command line?
Jake:开唱里边有命令行吗
Jake: Does karaoke have a command line?
Jake:你用同样的命令去跑他
Jake: Use the same command to run it.
Shure:  要有一个界面就是ui界面ui做的
Shure: There should be a UI interface, the UI is made.
Jake:那你可以命令行他跳出来
Jake: You can make it pop up with the command line.
Shure: 啊也可以是吧
Shure: Ah, that works too, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 然后这样的话就ok了
Shure: Then it's okay.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:你就跳过拍唱他的这个傻逼东西
Jake: Just skip the karaoke, that stupid thing.
Jake:好这答辩了这呵呵呵
Jake: Alright, this concludes the defense, haha.
Shure: 哦对我当时好像确实是这么弄的
Shure: Oh right, I think that's how I did it back then.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Shure: 感谢杨老板一会给你刷一个穿云箭
Shure: Thanks, Jake. I'll send you a cloud arrow later.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Shure: how can i help you today
Shure: How can I help you today?
Shure: today we will talk about
Shure: Today we will talk about...
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure: perfect
Shure: Perfect.
Jake:也能够圣旨上来
Jake: Also, can we bring the decree up?
Shure: 我们用中文还是用英文
Shure: Should we use Chinese or English?